Now that we know how to run
a simple sample, and how it looks,
let's talk about what notification
features are possible on Android Wear.
The first thing we can do is add extra
action buttons to a notification.
The user can view these actions by
swiping the notification to the left.
These actions are also visible on
the phone notification as well, so
this is not wearable specific.
So you make a call to
the addAction method
of the notification compact builder.
You need to supply an icon to use, and
you also need to provide
a string to show underneath, and
finally you'll need to provide a pending
intent for the specific action.
You'll notice that this code
snippet creates a pending intent
that refers to a location, so
it would open up a mapping application
to display this on the phone.
It is important to realize that
notifications created on the phone
always cause the intent to run on
the phone as well, not the wearable.
It's also possible to have different
actions appear on the wearable
device compared to
the actions on the phone.
To do this, we introduce a class
called WearableExtender for
wearable specific
features we want to use.
We use the extend method of
NotificationCompat.Builder, and
pass in the new WearableExtender object.
With WearableExtender,
we call addAction here
to add the wearable specific action,
which is defined here.
Note that when you use addAction
with the WearableExtender,
none of the regular addAction calls
will show up on the wearable, and
none of the wearable addAction
calls will be shown on the phone.
They're decoupled from each other now.